das ist nämlich eine Schlange drin
Riesenschlange da freue ich mich auch
richtig drüber dass der schon hier weg
das ist nicht nur ein Paradies für uns
sondern auch für ganz viele Tiere wir
haben diesen Bauernhof von 1850 gekauft
der hat einen richtig tollen Garten mit
alten Obstbäumen und wo es wirklich an
jeder Ecke was zu entdecken gibt und ich
gebe euch jetzt eine Tour
[Musik]
datrieben ist der Bärengarten und unser
wunderschöner Gartenschuppen darüber
erzähle ich euch gleich noch mehr aber
wir gehen jetzt erstmal nach oben wie
man sieht sind hier lauter Obstbäume das
ist zum Beispiel eine Quitte wir haben
hier ganz viele Birnen Kirschen Äpfel
Zwetschgen es gibt sogar ein oder zwei
Maronen Holunder Pflanzen in der Woche
in den Pfirsichbaum Mirabelle
es gibt quasi alles was ihr da seht ist
mein zukünftiges Büro weil ich ja immer
ganz viel im Garten Filme und dann
schneide und deswegen möchte ich diesen
Teil der Scheune gerne isolieren einen
schönen Fußboden reinmachen das Glas ist
es teilweise noch Plexiglas dann kommt
ein kleiner Ofen rein und dann wird das
ein richtig schönes kleines Wurzelwerk
Büro und hier kommen wir in unsere
Sitzecke da vorne ist eine Feuerstelle
wir haben schon einige Feuer gemacht da
hinten ist so ein Teil des Gartens der
ist noch ein bisschen verwilderter also
wir haben hier so teile wo wir das Gras
auch ein bisschen höher werden lassen
hier leben nämlich auch ganz viele
Molche haben wir schon gesehen es gibt
ganz viele Mäuse was gibt's noch alle
möglichen Insekten ganz viele Vögel es
sind auch ganz viele Nistkästen schon
überall aufgehängt ein paar haben wir
auch noch aufgehängt das ist nicht nur
ein Paradies für uns sondern auch für
ganz viele Tiere was richtig toll ist an
diesem Garten ist dass die Vorbesitzer
schon ganz viel gepflanzt haben die
haben zum Beispiel hier eine kernlose
Weintraube gepflanzt die sind so lecker
hängt auch gerade richtig voll da hinten
sieht man eine Brombeere die ist riesig
die hat riesige Früchte die sind auch
richtig richtig lecker hat gerade noch
ein bisschen rum da muss ich mich noch
drum kümmern wir sind ja gerade erst
eingezogen
ist ist das hier ganz viele
Natursteinmauern sind da leben auch jede
Menge Tiere drin das ist immer meine
tolle Sache wenn man eine Mauer machen
will dann lieber eine Natursteinmauer da
oben sieht man so ein richtiges riesigen
Walnussbaum der ist auch noch bei uns
auf dem Grundstück wir haben so viele
Haselnüsse dass wir endlos Haselnüsse
essen können selbst bei mir in der 100
Tage Selbstversorger Challenge wo ich
jeden Morgen mich quasi von Haselnüsse
ernährt habe
zu essen
so hier kommen wir in den oberen Teil
des Gartens und das ist der Teil wo auch
der Gemüsegarten hinkommt hier darf Elli
nicht rein ich zeige euch aber erstmal
hier das Herz des Gemüsegartens das ist
die Kompost Ecke da ist auch schon
einiges vorhanden also es gibt einige
Behälter ich glaube wenn man hier einmal
ein bisschen klar Schiff macht
vielleicht noch ein zwei Sachen aus
besser hat dann kann man hier eine
richtig tolle Kompostwirtschaft
einrichten wer er hat etwas das ist
unser Kompost Klo guck mal was das für
ein cooles Dach hat da wächst einfach
eine regelblume runter also das ist eine
Kompost Toilette und das ist eine
Toilette da kann man seine eigenen
Ausscheidung kompostieren wenn man sowas
machen möchte also ich finde das an sich
eigentlich eine coole Sache aber ich
finde es ein bisschen ekelhaft dass dann
im Gemüsegarten zu verwenden man muss
das dann mindestens zwei Jahre
kompostieren damit man nicht Parasiten
wieder vermehrt hier ist ein großer
Steinhaufen der liegt hier erst seit
zwei Tagen ich ich mal was ich aus den
Steinen bauen will ungefähr hier möchte
ich so gemauerte ungefähr so hohe
Hochbeete haben mit Frühbeet Hauben weil
wir haben auch noch ganz viele alte
Fenster bei uns in der Scheune stehen
und daraus könnte man glaube ich richtig
tolle Frühbeete bauen der Gemüsegarten
ist jetzt der Teil hier der besteht
schon der ist ziemlich verwildert ich
werde den gerne noch ein bisschen hier
in die Richtung vergrößern eine Sache wo
wir gerade viel dran arbeiten sind hier
diese Beton Einfassungen weil ich möchte
keine bildeinfassungen im inneren Teil
des Gemüsegartens haben weil ich immer
ganz viel mit Milch arbeite den ziehe
ich dann immer wieder auf die Wege im
Gemüsegarten und da ist so eine Bild
einfach so einfach unnötig und stört und
deswegen müssen wir die alle rausholen
und das ist so viel Arbeit aber ähm ich
werde jetzt den Herbst und Winter über
den Gemüsegarten hier komplett
umgestalten ich bin noch am überlegen ob
ich das Gelände noch mal ein bisschen
therapiere weil das schon sehr
abschüssig ist es im Gemüsegarten auch
nicht so ideal also ob wir weil wir eine
Zisterne bauen unten haben wir
Mutterboden übrig einen Teil davon hier
so ausbringen dass das Gefälle ein
bisschen ausgleicht aber ist noch nicht
in Stein gemeißelt also diese ganzen
gemüsegartenpläne sind noch
ja Waage ja genau hier gibt es einige
Pflanzen das hier ist zum Beispiel
grüner Spargel da freue ich mich auch
richtig drüber dass der schon hier
wächst eine kleine Geschichte am Rand
ich weiß gar nicht ob mein Freund der
gerade filmt sich daran noch erinnert
als wir uns kennengelernt haben habe ich
gerade den Hof hier gekauft gehabt und
dann war er noch nicht klar ob jetzt das
jetzt wirklich ernst zwischen uns ist
oder nicht ich habe gesagt dass ich
Spargelpflanzen möchte und ob er grün
oder weißen lieber mag dass ich den dann
auf jeden Fall Pflanze für ihn und dann
war wollten wir aber beide Grünen haben
und dann war das aber irgendwie so dass
klar war ich hätte auch weißen für ihn
gepflanzt und das war dann für ihn
sozusagen das Indiz dass ich ernst mit
ihm meine wenn ich auf meinem neuen Hof
was für ihn pflanzen will weiß nicht ob
die Geschichte
ob das irgendwie anders sieht aber ich
finde es irgendwie süß
genau und dann mussten
alles voll und die brauchen ein paar
Jahre bis die überhaupt tragen deswegen
ist das auch sehr toll das ist hier
schon welche gibt da unten gibt's schon
Erdbeeren die ganzen Pflanzen die hier
wachsen oder die meisten werde ich
ausgraben müssen wenn wir den Garten
umgestalten dann wieder einpflanzen da
gibt's ein riesen Salbei
das gigantisch die müssen wir auch
retten auf jeden Fall hier wird ganz
viel gerettet aber nicht alles manche
Sachen müssen auch weichen hier kommt
übrigens mein Gewächshaus hin und dann
sei ein ganz langer Weg vom einen Ende
des Gemüsegartens auf das Gewächshaus zu
verlaufen der wird ungefähr da sein und
den Gemüsegarten erweitere ich noch am
Stück in die Richtung und hier liebe
Leute haben wir eine Benjeshecke das ist
auch ein richtig tolles zu Hause für
alle möglichen Tiere wie zum Beispiel
für ihn und hier geht der haselnussraum
weiter schaut mal wie viele Nüsse hier
dran hängt also wenn ich mir das so
angucke dann kann die nächste Challenge
kommen vielleicht kriege ich diesmal ja
sogar meine Freund überredet mitzumachen
irgendwann
[Musik]
eine andere Seite
die Bäume tragen fast alle nicht so
wirklich gut ich glaube die könnten auch
mal wieder einen Schnitt vertragen das
auf viel Totholz in den Kronen hier
ein Paradies für Kinder und die Riemen
oder ist mein Heft ah das habe ich schon
gesucht oh nein
[Musik]
das schreibe ich alle meine wichtigen
Sachen rein
stimmt hier ist noch einer hier waren
richtig viele riesengroßeltern wir haben
schon die ganze Zeit gedacht wir würden
so gern welche essen aber die waren gut
als wenn ich da waren und jetzt sind sie
ziemlich eklig das sind eigentlich so
richtig schneeweiße kugelrunde Pilze aus
denen man richtig teuer Steaks machen
kann hier ist auch noch was richtig
tolles das fanden wir auch beim
Besichtigen einfach wunderschön hier
kommt man in so eine richtig richtig
schöne Höhle
wir haben wir vorhin auch Gelegenheit
es ist so ein grünes Blätter Dach
überein
ist echt ein besonderer Ort
so auf zum Garten shoppen da ist was
drin was richtig gefährliches vorsicht
wenn wir die Tür jetzt aufmachen da ist
nämlich eine Schlange drin
Riesenschlange die liegt hier auf dem
Boden weil ich zu faul war die
aufzuräumen vor dem Video also das ist
ein wunderschöner Gartenschuppen den
haben die vorherigen Besitzer selber
gebaut der hat so viele schöne Details
ich habe den jetzt komplett ausgeräumt
und sauber gemacht noch nicht überall
diesen Raum hier schon ein bisschen ich
mache einen komplettes Make-Over Video
von der Gartenhütte das also ein großes
Projekt und das werdet ihr auch bald auf
meinem Kanal sehen also abonniert und
das ist für den Bärengarten den möchte
ich auch umgestalten dazu kommt
wahrscheinlich auch ein Video und hier
habe ich schon Preiselbeeren gekauft und
goldene Himbeeren aber da kommen noch
viel mehr bärensträucher weil wir haben
noch lange nicht genug
das hier ist so ein richtig cooles
Hochbeet was hier im Garten ist und hier
gibt's einfach einen also nicht von oben
das heißt ich kann hier perfekt meine
Jungpflanzen Anzucht machen hier kommt
zum Tisch hin wahrscheinlich hier so ein
Regal damit ich mich hier perfekt
einrichten kann auch die Auszeit Videos
hier für euch drehen kann diese Fenster
sind auch der Hammer ja hier haben wir
noch ein richtig großen Raum da kann man
also ich hätte vorher gerne so eine
Leseecke hier drin aber auch Stauraum
natürlich für das ganze Garten Equipment
hier sind noch
gefährliche kleine Dinos drin
erst eingezogen deswegen wollen wir die
gar nicht groß stören
aber die steht im Wasser hat umgekippt
das sind unsere neuen Hühner die sind
heute gekommen
[Musik]
aber ihr könnt ja mal in die Kommentare
schreiben was ihr machen würdet mit dem
Gartenhäuschen und dann seid gespannt
auf das Make-up aber ich glaube das wird
ein richtig richtig cooles Video
wenn wir noch mal hier sind dann gucken
wir wenigstens auch mal wie schön die
nestboxen sind und hier hinten gibt's
einfach eine
kleine futterabteilung hier sind die
ganzen Futtereimer und hier gibt's eine
riesige Kelle guck mal
schimpfen kann wir brauchen mehr
Hühnergehege das ist so ein richtiges
Paradies
[Musik]
ist das Tor braucht noch ein bisschen
Liebe die Hühner dürfen erst morgen raus
weil die sich heute noch mal eingewöhnen
müssen es ist sehr wild das mögen Hühner
natürlich es gibt viele Bäume als Schutz
vor Greifvögeln und hier ist der
perfekte hühnerbaum oder ich stelle mir
vor dass die hier immer sitzen so
mittags wenn es zu warm ist haben wir
hier ihre kleine ansitzstange aber die
ist es auf jeden Fall auch so sicher und
Fuchs sicher weil der ganze Steuer
richtig gut gebaut ist so und das ist
hier jetzt der Bärengarten in dem wir
kommen hier gibt's schon richtig viele
tolle bärenstreicher guck mal wie
gigantisch die sind das sind die
osterbären da haben wir auch wahnsinnig
viel von geerntet sie gefühlt die halbe
Tiefkühltruhe voll hier haben wir zum
Beispiel Stachelbeeren also es gibt fast
alles aber eben die Sachen die ich noch
nicht gibt wie z.B Blaubeeren die kommen
da hinten vor die Wand wer errät was das
hier ist hier haben wir Himbeeren
[Musik]
und da müssen aber auch noch mehr hinten
oh eine Sache
so bist du in der Nacktschnecke gedreht
ja das wird eine große Herausforderung
wir sind überall Schnecken oh pass auf
kurz noch habe ich mit den Mitleid weil
wir kein Gemüse haben also der Garten
wird im Frühling irgendwann fertig dann
fange ich nächste Saison an wieder zu
Gärten an und da freue ich mich schon
wahnsinnig drauf jetzt zeige ich euch
was richtig cooles indem bei uns da
wohnen Wildbienen ist das nicht cool und
hier wollen wir eine ganz große Zisterne
eingraben weil wir nämlich ganz viel
scheunenfläche haben also auch
Dachfläche wo es draußen regnet und dann
können wir Regenwasser auffangen für
unseren Gemüsegarten im Moment haben wir
auch einen Brunnen aber da müssen wir
eben ans Grundwasser gehen und das
Wasser nutzen und ich finde es einfach
viel schöner wenn man das Regenwasser
aufhängt und nutzt und es gibt auch
überall hier Möglichkeiten das Wasser
was man aus dem Brunnen nimmt oder auch
aus der Leitung also wir haben beides
hier als Anschluss im Gartenhäuschen
dass man das auffängt mit einem Eimer
und dann im Garten weiter verwendet ist
das nicht cool dass man hier im Garten
so Waschbecken hat um die Ernte sauber
zu machen ich finde das so schön eigenes
Gemüse anzubauen aber die Küche ist
immer voll mit Erde und wenn man hier
die Karotten schon mal abwäscht und das
Wasser dann auffängt dann verstopft es
keinen Abfluss und ist perfekt wenn man
es wieder verwendet lasst auf jeden Fall
gerne ein Abo da wenn Ihr sehen wollt
wie es hier mit dem Bauernhof weitergeht
und ansonsten zeige ich euch da drüben
ein Video wo ich die hoftour mache also
wo wir durch das Haus und die Scheunen
gehen wenn ihr das noch nicht gesehen
habt dann schaut auf jeden Fall vorbei
ansonsten geh drauf mach die Welt ein
bisschen grüner und wir sehen uns
nächstes Mal wieder macht's gut tschüss